My RIFE indicates program duration can be changed by changing the duty cycle or duty number.
Is that okay? The Italian Robin.
So the Italian Robin and the true RIFE program use that same command called duty.
So the duty of number is on your Italian Robin has to do with the amount of time that the frequency is on a certain number.
So if you're going to want to change the duration of a program, the length of a program, you don't change the duty cycle.
You change the command that's called dwell.
So dwell is the command on both the true RIFE and the Italian Robin that tells you how long it's going to dwell on a given frequency.
So let's say it says dwell 180.
Alright, let's do it this way.
So let's say the program says dwell 180.
Then underneath it it has, I don't know, let's just put in some numbers here.
Five, four, six and two, three, four and ten thousand, four hundred and fifty six.
So then it's got another line with with some numbers and like this.
And then it's got another line with some numbers.
That means these are the frequencies that are being dwelled on for 180 seconds.
So there are certain commands in the RIFE program that the program itself will ignore the letters dwell and will ignore whatever comes after that on that same line.
180. And it doesn't sense that as a frequency that is being run, that's being run or being asked to be run on the following lines.
If there's not a command dwell or duty or pulse or things like that, those are certain commands that tell the machine to do certain things.
And it's just a number that that's the frequency that is running or will run in the program.
Do not mess with these numbers.
If you mess with these numbers, you've literally changed your program.
What your program is, it consists of duty cycles, dwells, pulse commands, all sorts of different commands.
And it consists of the numbers which are the frequencies that are running.
Dwelled is how long it stays on a given frequency in numbers of seconds.
So this is 180 seconds, dwelling 180 seconds.
Everything below that line until the dwell is switched again.
And if it says dwell 90, then it has a bunch of other numbers after that.
As long as you put a comma between the numbers, that means that's the frequency of 2,345 and the frequency of 4,556.
Or you have it on a separate line like I did with these.
So that means you're continuing to run that.
So now the dwell has changed.
The dwell has changed to now it'll only run these two frequencies at 90 seconds each.
So that's how those are those commands.
I recommend you don't mess with them at all.
If you mess with the duty cycle, you're going to screw up the program completely.
Do not ever mess with the duty cycle because there are certain rules in writing programs that have to do with duties.
So if you go into your program and you're playing with the duty cycle, you could wreck your machine.
So it's just as simple as that.
With the true right.
With either machine, you could just you can burn out, you can, you can load a machine.
So you never mess with the duty cycles.
Okay.
Or you can, but your, your machine is going to not work.
And you're going to be calling me to have it fixed.
So don't ever mess with the duty cycles.
Don't ever mess with the pulses.
Don't ever mess you, the only thing that I would say that you could safely play with is the dwell.
You can't hurt anything by changing the dwell.
Well, let's take that back.
You could hurt you by changing the dwell.
Technically, I don't ever have anything dwell on anything more than.
Usually on an average frequency.
There are some frequencies that you can dwell up to 30 minutes.
But on the average, you're dwelling less than 300 seconds.
So, um, so, but let's say you change this to 18,000.
Well, all your program is going to be like 20 hours long, probably.
But, um, you, by just by changing that.
It's not safe to be dwelling on these frequencies that long.
So, um, I just, I realize that you want to get technical and you want to do this yourself.
I'm all poor.
This is your machine.
You do whatever you want to do.
But don't do things foolishly.
Okay.
So, um, don't ever, ever mess with the duty cycles.
And if you do mess with the dwells, let's say, let's say you wanted to turn a,
let's say you were running a, a flu program, but it was only 90 minutes long.
Uh, I want to make this nine hours.
Well, you don't just change the dwell and let it dwell on each frequency for 10 minutes.
That's not good for you either.
So, I just asked me to write a program that's going to make a nine hour flu program.
That's what you wanted.
So, uh, not giving you about telling you you can't do whatever you want to do with your machine.
But if you hurt yourself with your machine, that's on you.
So, if you hurt your machine, that's on you too.
So, um, just be careful.